-How are you?
-I am great.
-I'm so happy to hear this.
I know that you go back
from recess tomorrow.
-Yes.
-So tell me, during the recess,
do you miss it?
Do you miss your colleagues?
Do you miss your colleagues from
the other side of the aisle?
-Let me put it this way.
I am ready to get back
in the fight.
-All right.
-Anytime.
-There you go.
-That's my job.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wonderful to hear.
I will say, your message
is a very strong one.
I find it very counter
to what your favorite show is.
When I think of what Elizabeth
Warren's favorite show is,
I would not guess
that it is "Ballers."
[ Laughter ]
-But it is.
-That's true. Okay.
Because you did tweet, "To all
the reporters tweeting at me
about the season premiere of
'Ballers' on Sunday night
at 10:00 p.m.,
like I haven't had this date
saved on my calendar for months:
I know."
-True. I know.
-You know, and by the way,
someone else noticed your tweet.
This is Dwayne "The Rock"
Johnson, the star of "Ballers."
"You reporters
better put some respect
on Senator Warren's name.
She is ready for our season
premiere of 'Ballers.'"
And then, "Thank you, Senator,
for the support.
I feel
we'll deliver our best yet.
You have a big Rock-sized hug
coming when I see you."
-Whoa.
-I mean, that is --
-That's good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I would say a Rock-size hug
is both very exciting
and also very terrifying.
Just be a little careful
about a Rock-size hug.
-Yeah. It's a thing.
-You were here in 2014,
and it seems very long ago you
were considered, at the time,
the far left end of
the Democratic Party.
There has been
a progressive wave, it seems,
post the 2016 election.
Are you surprised
it took this long,
or are you relieved
that it's finally happening?
-Oh, look, I look at this as
people are starting to ask
the fundamental question.
Who does government work for?
And, boy, has that become
even clearer
over the last year and a half.
The Republicans passed
this gigantic tax giveaway.
$1.5 trillion to giant
corporations and bazillionaires.
That's who they think government
should work for,
that the rich and the powerful
should get richer
and more powerful.
My view on this and a lot of
folks around this country is,
no, government ought to
work for the people,
and that's what
this fight is all about.
That's how I see this.
-Was it frustrating for you
having been, you know,
a politician who had always
talked about the middle class
and actually taken steps
to protect the middle class
to see Donald Trump
also frame himself
as a hero of the middle class?
-Sure. But now, it's not
even about the words.
It's about what have you
actually done?
You give away $1.5 trillion
to the richest and most powerful
among us?
I just want to think
for a minute
what you really could do
if you were investing that money
in America.
And on this,
I want to say for me,
this is really personal
because this is about
how government works.
I grew up in one of these
paycheck-to-paycheck families.
My daddy ended up as a janitor.
My mom worked a minimum-wage job
at Sears.
My chance in life was a $50
a semester commuter college.
I grabbed it and hung on,
and I got to be
a public schoolteacher.
I got to be a college professor,
and I got to be
a United States Senator
all because America
invested in kids like me.
I believe in that America.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you take -- I mean,
solace is a weird word,
but have you --
do you find it notable
that right now as we come
towards the midterms,
it seems as though
the Republican Party
is not actually running on this
tax bill they passed, which...
-No kidding.
-...is the signature achievement
of the first half of
Donald Trump's term in office.
-And stinks like
three-week-old garbage.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, they are, "Oh..."
You know, somewhere else
every time
anything about that tax bill
comes up.
You know, and that's what's
remarkable about this.
They passed it
knowing it was unpopular.
It's not like people
changed their minds.
They passed it
knowing it was unpopular.
Figured, "Hey, they'd spend
a few bazillion dollars
outrunning ads on it,
and the American people
would fall for it."
And here's the deal.
It's more unpopular now than it
was when it passed because,
I think that really is the heart
of where America is.
I think we still fundamentally,
fundamentally, down at our core,
believe in the things
we can do together.
Believe in the things
like healthcare
is a basic human right,
and our kids should be able
to get an education
without getting crushed by debt,
and that seniors should be able
to retire with some dignity
and that we're willing to pull
together to pitch in
some of our money
to try to make that happen,
to build a better future
for ourselves and for our kids.